[Joke video] Hi everyone welcome back to another
video. So a little while ago I made a
video covering this exam here that I'm
holding in my hand and it's more of a
test, it's an IQ test and it was one of
the ones from Mensa New Zealand saying
that if you can do well on this maybe
you'll have a good shot at getting into
Mensa, a high IQ society. That has turned
out to be a pretty popular video and
people love challenging themselves on
some of these problems but every time I
think about it I sort of think
about the idea of trying to test
intelligence based on a set of right and
wrong answers which essentially this
test is, it's saying that some of these
patterns are more valid than others and
you need to find the same patterns that
the person who wrote the answers also
found but I want to take a little look
at this exam, with the question in mind
you know, can any answer be correct? and
can you basically fit a pattern to any
sequence of shapes or numbers? and you
know, what would someone with a 300
IQ do if they were to approach one of
these tests? Just to clarify I do know
that IQs of say over 140 would be
considered a genius level so saying IQ
300 I know is a bit of a joke and this
video is a bit of a joke but at least
maybe it can be a bit of insight into
the idea of overfitting or, you know,
fitting overly complicated patterns to
the data which, you know, model every
single data point and capture all of the
noise and random data points as well not
just the general trend of the data which
can be a genuine problem to
have if you're working in say machine
learning or something like that
or just trying to predict anything. You
actually lose your predictive powers if
you start to over fit your data or model
it too closely. Back before we knew that
the earth and planets orbited around the
we had some models such as the Ptolemy's
model that earth was at the center of
the solar system and some of these
scientists came up with more and more
intricate and complicated models to try
and explain every single, you know, data
point they could find. They had to come
up with elaborate, you know, circles and
loops that big planets were following
which would explain why they appeared to
be moving back and forwards in the sky
if they were orbiting the Earth. I think
it got to a point where this model was
just so complicated trying to explain
everything in the wrong way that
ultimately it was better just to adopt a
new model that made more sense. This
video is filmed on the 31st of July
which is Harry Potter's birthday so
these glasses are reference to that but
also perhaps they will give me the
necessary IQ points that I need to
answer some of these. So here's the exam
and if you've seen my previous video
this will be familiar to you. Now let's
just start with looking at the very
first question here. Now the first one is
asking us to complete the next in the
pattern or in the series so we've got
a, d, g, j now the low IQ or average IQ way
to answer this would be to say that
there are two letters missing between
each letter here and the answer given
in the answers is M but I thoroughly
disagree with that seeing as we can do
this a much better way [sarcasm]. So what we could
do is naturally assign each of our
letters to their numeral in the alphabet
so A would give us one, D would
correspond to four, G to seven and J to
ten. Our sequence is now 1, 4, 7, 10 if we
can find the next number in this series,
translate it back into a letter we will
have an answer. So what are we going to
do to find the next number in this
series? Well I'm going to do the thing
that I think would be natural and
that's to fit a polynomial to these
numbers here. You know, you can have
polynomials of increasing degree to
model basically any sequence you want so
I'm going to model this with a fourth
degree polynomial which is as follows
301 over 24 X to the 4 minus 1505/12...
and there's my polynomial there. You can
check my working if you wish to. If we
plug in an X value of one we will get a
y value of one. If we plug in X is equal
to two we will get four. X is equal to
three we will be at seven, X is equal to
four will get ten and X is equal to five
which is really what we're trying to
generate here, our fifth number in the
series, well X is equal to five would
give us a y-value of 314. I quite like
that because it's you know an
approximation of pi. Now the only problem
is translating it back to a letter well
there's not 314 letters in the alphabet
there are however 26 letters in the
alphabet so if we do three one four mod
26 we would get an answer of two [should be mod25]. Okay
I'm sure you know how mod works it's
basically the remainder if we were to
divide it by 26 we've got a mod of 2
which would correspond to a letter B and
now that would be my final answer to the
question. It does not agree with the
answer given by the answers but I think
there is nothing wrong with the way I've
got it and it is perfectly valid [joke]. So
moving on, the next one that I'd like to
try is number 15 up here it's one of
these visual ones. I've watched a few
episodes of Rick and Morty before I
filmed this video so I should be fine
with coming up with something. Now for
the sake of it I will give you what the
answer says are the correct answers here.
So we're again finding the next one in
the series, we've got one two three. The answers say that number C 😂is the correct
answer for what comes next and they say
this is true because the dash oscillates
between these diagonal spaces so would
oscillate back to here and the dot moves
around clockwise so it would meet the
dash there. I mean you could do that or
you could do my method. Now there's a
little bit of setup for my method
but essentially when I look at a
square like the one given I imagine it
in a point system where being in this
spot here would give you one point, here
would give you two, three and four points.
Now let's have a look at the behavior of
the dot in the first three elements. So
in the first one it's in position 1 the
dot has accumulated 1 point and the
second one it moves across to spot 2. It's
now got an additional two points and in
this third one it's moved down to have
an additional 3 points. 1+2+3, at the end
of this the dot is on a tally of 6
points. Now let's look at the behavior of
the dash, it starts off in the 2 so it has 2
then we can add to that 4 and then we
can add to that another 2 now you know
we've got a tally of points for both of
them but what are we going to do with
that? Well the only logical thing to do
with that would be to think okay
we've got you know one more element in
the series and wouldn't it be great if
with that one last iteration we could
make the points for both of the shapes
equal. Now there are a couple of ways
that this could happen actually and I'll
draw the two possible options for the
fourth item in the series so the
dot and the dash, well we've got 6 and we've
got 8, well we could imagine that they
could go on to both equal 9 where the
dot could gain an additional 3 so it
would have to be here and the dash would
gain an additional 1 so it would be here.
I guess that would be one option where
the tally would come to a total of 9. Our
other option is to bring the tally both
to a total of 10 so the dot would have
to gain an additional 4 placing it here
the dash would have to gain an additional 2
placing it here. Alright so that gives
as both a total of 10. If we look up to
our possible answers to pick from this
option here does not appear as an option
but this option here does so I would say
that my better and more correct answer [joke]
would be B. I say the phrase 'more
correct' but of course I mean that they
both could be correct depending on what
you're looking for here if you're
looking for a IQ 300 play you know maybe
that's what I've shown you but if you're
looking for how to score well on this
test being marked by whoever is marking
it then you'll have to try and simplify
your reasoning down to give an answer of C.
I'll try out one last one on the last
page okay so number 30 is a little bit
different from what we've done already
we are wanting to find out what shape
would go in this box here so there's
obviously some pattern things are
following and to make it a little tricky
they've blocked out these two squares so
we can't see what was going on there but
we can still work out the pattern fine
enough. Now a quick glance of the answers
do say that A is the expected answer for
this so let's see if we agree with them.
Now first of all I want to find out what
is happening between this first line and
the second line so just from looking
at it I can see a sort of a pattern
already, if we count the number of sides
on the smaller shape and divide it by
the number of sides on the larger shape
well what we would get is that the cross
has 12 sides,
the box has four sides, that division would
give us three but if we were to square
three we would get nine and if we were
to times that by 10 we would get 90
degrees because that is how much it
rotates in terms of where it's flying
off to between this line and the
line. Here it flies out to the right, here
this little box appears to be flying
down, you know downwards, so that's a
difference of 90 degrees. If we do the
same logic I think we can find out what
kind of rotation this box would undergo
when it turns into a dot and what angle
it would fly off at. So let's count the
number of sides of the little shape, we
have four so that would be four divided
by well a circle has one side so that would be four
over one, that would be four, four squared
would be 16, times 10 would give us 160
degrees, so if this one is starting from
the downwards position we want to rotate
160 degrees well that would be 90 and
then would have 70 more we would expect
a triangle with a circle flying out at
160 degrees relative to the base so I
would expect that to be
somewhere like there. Now that doesn't
quite perfectly match any of our answers,
this one it flies out to the bottom, to
the top, to the right well it's
definitely none of those so I would
agree that A fits our pattern most
precisely although not exactly and there
you go I've solved a few problems there
and I guess you can try out the rest of
them for yourself if you haven't already
from my last video. So don't take that too
seriously it was really just a bit
of fun to see if we can fit a model to
anything we want to and kind of force
our way to any answer possible.
I guess there's something to say for, you
know, trying to measure intelligence from
one set of answers, whether mine are more intelligent or less intelligent
is up to the viewer to decide but thank
you for watching.